y
[Música]
el presidente de eeuu joe biden llegó a
arabia saudita y se reunió con el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman en
una polémica parada de su gira por medio
oriente el mandatario norteamericano
dice que hizo responsable al monarca del
asesinato del periodista llama al show
autoridades mexicanas arrestaron a
rafael caro quintero uno de los diez
prófugos más buscados por eeuu la
antigua vida del desaparecido cártel de
guadalajara estuvo al frente de una
organización que sembró el terror en los
años 80 washington celebró la detención
y pedirá su extradición
más de 300 personas han perdido la vida
en españa y portugal debido a las altas
temperaturas que deja la ola de calor
que golpea varios puntos de europa a
esto se suman los incendios forestales
que son combatidos por bomberos locales
por primera vez en su historia el reino
unido- emitió una alerta roja por el
calor extremo
tiempo de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de france 24 yo soy juana
pupiales gracias por estar con nosotros
un saludo que sacudió a los defensores
de los derechos humanos y en especial a
familiares del asesinado periodista
disidente llamar a jogging el presidente
de eeuu joe biden se reunió este viernes
con el príncipe heredero saudí mohammed
bin salman quien según la inteligencia
de washington aprobó la muerte del
comunicador rafael pérez nos habla de
esta polémica visita por parte de bailén
un frío choque de puños dio inicio a un
polémico encuentro iovine presidente de
eeuu y mohamed bin salman príncipe
heredero de arabia saudita finalmente
cara a cara las agencias de inteligencia
de eeuu señalaron a bin salman como
autor intelectual del asesinato del
periodista amalia giorgi en 2018
un hecho que alejó a ambos países tras
la victoria de bardem quien en su
campaña de 2019 prometió que haría pagar
un precio a los líderes del estado que
calificó entonces de faria el caso del
periodista salió a la población durante
la reunión y
aire al respecto al asesinato de hacks
ops y lo planté en un momento de la
reunión dejando claro lo que pensé en
ese momento y lo que pienso ahora soy
franco y directo al discutirlo de que mi
punto de vista muy claro lo dije muy
claramente
fue un presidente de los estadounidenses
guarde silencio sobre el tema de los
derechos humanos es inconsistente con
quienes somos y con quién soy
quién fue la prometida de hudson y
publicó lo que supuestamente hubiese
tuiteado su pareja hola presidente es
esta la rendición de cuentas que
prometiste por mi asesinato la sangre de
la próxima víctima de envíes está en tus
manos joe biden prometió poner el tema
de los derechos humanos en el centro de
su política exterior por lo que su
visita a arabia saudita resulta polémica
y desata reacciones incluso dentro del
propio partido demócrata
si alguna vez necesitamos un
recordatorio visual del control continuo
de los autócratas ricos en petróleo
tienen sobre la política exterior de
eeuu en el medio oriente lo tenemos hoy
un golpe de puño vale más que mil
palabras
joe biden quedó entre la espada y la
pared el acercamiento con riad se ve
impulsado por un complejo contexto
internacional con impactos internos para
eeuu donde la inflación es la más alta
en 40 años consecuencia del alza en los
precios de la gasolina el objetivo
principal de bailén sería pedirle a sus
socios del golfo que incrementen la
producción de crudo para mitigar los
costos de los combustibles
previamente a su llegada a arabia
saudita el presidente joe biden se
reunió en velen para verse con mahmud
abás presidente de la autoridad nacional
palestina el jefe de la unión americana
defendió el plan de una solución con dos
estados una consigna plasmada por
primera vez en los acuerdos de oslo de
1993 sin embargo bailén reconoció que
esa meta se muestra muy lejana en este
momento por su parte abbas hizo un
llamado a washington para que colabore
con los territorios palestinos
esperamos con ansia los pasos de la
administración de eeuu para fortalecer
las relaciones bilaterales al reabrir el
consulado de eeuu en jerusalén este
eliminar la organización para la
liberación de palestina de la lista de
terroristas de eeuu no somos terroristas
y reabrir su oficina en washington y por
nuestra parte estamos dispuestos a
trabajar en el marco de la asociación y
la cooperación con el fin de eliminar
cualquier obstáculo para lograrlo
como avanzábamos en titulares la marina
mexicana arrestó este viernes a rafael
caro quintero uno de los líderes más
importantes del narcotráfico y quien
lideró al desaparecido cártel de
guadalajara una de las organizaciones de
ese tipo más poderosas en los años 80
quintero de 69 años cayó en choix una
localidad al norte del estado de sinaloa
uno de los bastiones del tráfico de
estupefacientes en el país fue una
sabueso militarmente entrenada la que
halló al capo entre unos arbustos es
recordado sobre todo por el asesinato y
tortura del agente de la dea enrique
kiki camarena en 1985 desde la
administración del presidente
estadounidense joe biden celebraron la
noticia y anunciaron que van a pedir su
extradición
el resto de hoy es la culminación del
trabajo incansable de la dea y sus
socios mexicanos para llevar a caro
quintero ante la justicia por sus
presuntos delitos incluida la tortura y
ejecución del agente especial de la dea
enrique kiki camarena estaremos buscando
su extradición inmediata a los eeuu para
que pueda ser juzgado por estos crímenes
en el mismo sistema de justicia que la
gente especial camarena murió
defendiendo
en pero el pleno del congreso votó a
favor de una reforma constitucional para
el retorno de la bicameralidad que será
decidido en un referéndum con 71 votos a
favor 45 en contra y 6 abstenciones el
pleno del legislativo votó la
controvertida propuesta el último día de
la legislatura no obstante la presidenta
de la comisión de constitución patricia
juárez indicó que pedirá una
reconsideración de la votación para
eliminar el trámite de ir a un referendo
la bicameralidad fue eliminada en la
reforma constitucional de 1993 por el
entonces presidente alberto fujimori
seguimos en este país porque por primera
vez en la historia la corte suprema
autorizó una aután hacia el fallo de
dictado del jueves permite a la
psicóloga anna estrada el acceso a una
muerte asistida
autorizan eutanasia en perú a na estrada
de 45 años que ha luchado contra una
enfermedad degenerativa y terminal yo
creo que la corte suprema de justicia le
permitiera acceder a este derecho cuatro
jueces votaron a favor y dos en contra
en un fallo que confirma una decisión
judicial previa
me siento muy satisfecha
muy agradecida
por qué
cuando empecé esto
no tenía mucho miedo mucho temor de que
no resultara o de que fuera
de repente todo en contra y más bien
resultó que reciben mucho apoyo hay
muchísima gente de a pie
he conocido a muchas personas muy
valiosas
y eso enriquecido este proceso la mujer
psicóloga de profesión padece polibio
cities desde los 12 años una enfermedad
que desgasta los músculos y no tiene
cura cuando cumplió 20 años empezó a
usar silla de ruedas debido a su
debilidad para caminar su abogado es
defensor del pueblo peruano aplaudió la
decisión de la corte declararon fundado
el derecho a la muerte digna es un
presidente fundamental es el primer caso
y ese irrevocable le permite a ésta
poder tomar decisión de poner fin a su
vida en un momento determinado en perú
donde la mayoría de la población es
católica muchos conservadores se oponen
a esta práctica en latinoamérica sólo
colombia aprueba la eutanasia con
intervención médica países como chile
méxico o argentina tienen regulaciones
que permiten a los pacientes rechazar
tratamientos que prolonguen la vida
artificialmente
europa sufre una grave ola de calor con
nuevos récords de temperaturas
superiores a los 40 grados celsius pero
además desde francia hasta grecia varios
países del viejo continente están
padeciendo múltiples incendios
forestales que han obligado a evacuar a
miles de personas de sus hogares unas
temperaturas y desastres ambientales
agravados por la crisis climática
mundial que ha elevado la temperatura de
la tierra marina sardiña con los
detalles
el sur de europa en llamas y marcando
récords de altas temperaturas que
superan los 40 grados celsius la
península ibérica' está sufriendo las
condiciones más secas de los últimos
1.000 años según la o m/m una ola de
calor que deja más de 300 muertos en
españa y portugal donde los bomberos
luchan contra múltiples incendios de
gran magnitud al terminar un día la alta
temperatura no es la única consecuencia
adversa de las olas de calor la
atmósfera estable y estancada actúa como
una tapa que atrapa los contaminantes
atmosféricos incluidas las partículas
aumentando su concentración más cerca de
la superficie el resultado es la
degradación de la calidad del aire y los
efectos adversos para la salud
especialmente para las personas
vulnerables tipo las bocanadas de aire
caliente y las llamas se extienden desde
el norte de áfrica hasta italia grecia o
reino unido que este viernes emitió la
alerta roja en el centro de la isla por
calor extremo la oficina de meteorología
advirtió que se podría superar los 40
grados también en francia miles de
personas han sido evacuadas de sus
hogares a medida que los incendios
forestales arrasan las regiones del
sureste del país
a excepción del pasado estamos viviendo
una temporada única en términos de
dificultad ya hemos visto el triple de
bosques quemadores en comparación con
2020 hemos tenido tanto una primavera
muy seca como incendios que han
comenzado con fuerza y sus olas de
player default y la deshidratación
golpes de calor y problemas
respiratorios por la degradación del
aire debido al humo y otras partículas
sostenidas en la atmósfera afectan a la
salud de millones de europeos y es que
miles de hectáreas arden cada verano en
europa una problemática agravada con el
calentamiento global pero también los
activistas denuncian que existe un lobby
de los incendios empresas que cobran por
apagar fuegos con fuertes intereses
económicos urbanísticos y a veces
enfocados en la venta de madera el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
pidió este viernes se reconoció la rusa
como estado terrorista tras el ataque
del jueves contra la ciudad de benítez
ya un bombardeo que dejó 23 personas
muertas se les que agregó que existe la
necesidad de urgente de crear un
tribunal especial sobre la agresión rusa
a su país hosco por su parte
alegando que el ataque estaba dirigido a
un edificio en el que altos cargos de
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania se
reunían con proveedores de armas
extranjeros
seguimos hablando de la guerra en
ucrania porque un nuevo ataque ruso en
la ciudad en y prom dejó al menos tres
muertos y quince heridos los misiles
golpearon una planta industrial y una
calle cercana según el gobernador
regional catalina gómez ángel enviada
especial de 324 ucrania nos entregó más
detalles previamente en su reporte
este es uno de los pocos ataques tal vez
el cuarto que ha sufrido la ciudad de
beni pero desde que comenzó la guerra el
24 de febrero esta es una ciudad que no
solamente es la ciudad industrial de
ucrania sino que se ha convertido en un
centro estratégico especialmente en esta
lucha de la batalla por la región del
donbass está la ciudad de entrada hasta
esta zona del este por aquí tienen que
pasar muchísimos de los militares la
logística y también todas esas nuevas
armas que están dadas por occidente esto
hace que esta ciudad se haya convertido
básicamente en ese pulmón que necesita
el donbass para sobrevivir aquí llegan
también la mayoría de heridos que salen
de allí y lo que dicen las autoridades
es que tres misiles fueron lanzados
sobre la ciudad uno habría sido
interceptado y parece que una de esas
partes del misil que fue interceptada
cayó en una parte de esta calle otro
habría caído aquí cerca estas son todas
edificaciones muchas de ellas
gubernamentales y militares y otra en
una zona industrial de la ciudad que
como en la ciudad más importante de este
sector lo que vemos aquí es una cantidad
de militares haciendo la investigación
sobre lo que pasó esta noche en un
momento en que las grandes ciudades de
ucrania vuelven a ser atacadas con estos
misiles lo que crea ese sentimiento de
que a pesar de que muchas de ellas
vuelven a la normalidad como es el caso
de de niro donde hoy había muchísima
gente en la calle pues no tienen esa
seguridad que la gente piensa el primer
ministro al raml y wii cree mensaje
juramento como presidente interino de
civil anc a este alto funcionario
sucedió hacia gotabaya rajapaksa quien
abandonó el país el martes el rumbo a
singapur en medio de una gran agitación
social y una fuerte crisis económica el
parlamento debe ahora comenzar a elegir
a un encargado de terminar el resto del
mandato
escenas de gozo en la capital de sir
lanka en las calles de colombo cientos
de personas celebraron la dimisión del
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa
bueno hay un espíritu festivo en este
momento creo que la gente aquí está muy
contenta con esta decisión
una salida confirmada del viernes por la
mañana por el parlamento de es blanca la
carta de dimisión del presidente
rajapaksa enviada por correo electrónico
tras su llegada a singapur ha sido
validada
he recibido la dimisión del presidente
votaba ya raya pacsa de acuerdo con el
artículo 38 1 de la constitución de la
república socialista democrática de
decidir la ncaa en consecuencia el
presidente ha renunciado legalmente a la
presidencia
libia
el primer ministro running with crime
single es ahora el presidente en
funciones según la constitución el
parlamento tiene 30 días para nombrar a
su sucesor los diputados lo elegirán en
los próximos siete días
el tiempo se acaba sri lanka atraviesa
actualmente una grave crisis económica
la isla se enfrenta a cortes de
electricidad escasez de combustible
escasez de alimentos y una inflación
récord para salir de la crisis una
solución desbloquear las negociaciones
con el fondo monetario internacional y
obtener un plan de rescate
la información continua aquí en france24
y también en france24 punto com
[Música]